stormy Daniels is now suing president
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
for defamation the lawsuit claims Cohen
damaged the adult film stars reputation
in February by suggesting she was a liar
Cohen's lawyer says his client did
nothing wrong
Cohen has become a central figure in the
stormy Daniels controversy he's been at
the president's side for years mr. Trump
disputes Daniels claim that they had sex
in 2006 but Cohen admits paying her one
hundred thirty thousand dollars to
secure a non-disclosure agreement Paula
Reed is at the White House with why that
deal may have been a crime Paula good
morning good morning stormy Daniels told
60 minutes that she believes that the
president's personal attorney Michael
Cohen is behind those threats that she's
received but an attorney for mr. Cohen
denies that and said his client has only
tried to protect the president now Cohen
is famous for his loyalty to the
president but it is that loyalty that
has now possibly exposed him to an FEC
violation and it's what's put him in
Robert Muller sites as a matter of fact
the exact sentence used was they can
make your life hell in many different
ways they being I'm not exactly sure who
they were I believe it to be Michael
Cohen mr. Michael Cohen for the last
decade attorney Michael Cohen has been
part of the president's inner circle
providing legal counsel and serving as a
fixer a jack-of-all-trades who seemingly
can make unpleasant situations go away
we will do what it's necessary to
protect him and the press and the office
of the presidency he is a reputation for
using aggressive tactics in 2015 Cohen
allegedly threatened a Daily Beast
reporter the publication was working on
a story surrounding Ivana Trump's rape
allegation against her then-husband
which she has since recanted you write a
story that has mr. Trump's name in it
with the word rape and I'm going to mess
her life up Cohen reportedly said
Michael Cohen has zero credibility
stormy Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
says Cohen has a history of using
thuggish behavior and intimidation to
protect his boss David Schwartz and
efore : maintains his client did nothing
wrong mr. Cohen paid the hundred thirty
thousand dollars but the reason is to
protect business protect reputation and
to protect family but the timing of the
payment eleven days before the election
raises red flags as a possible violation
of federal campaign law Jim Whaley is a
former federal prosecutor mr. Cohen is
getting himself in deeper legal problems
that could make him more vulnerable in
the mulher investigation I don't think
that necessarily benefits others that
are potentially the topic of that
investigation including the president
United States himself sources tell me
it's unlikely that Special Counsel
Robert Muller would independently pursue
Cohen's deal with stormy Daniels because
it doesn't have anything to do with
Russians or the Russian government but
we do know that the Special Counsel is
looking into certain events that Cohen
was involved in and if special counsel
investigators uncover any possible
evidence that Cohen was paying hush
money in advance of the election to help
president Trump get elected the special
counsel could recommend that to the
Justice Department for possible
prosecution Nora
all right Paula thank you so much